filipinos like to
to gather around food
and when we do that we normally you know
like if we invite you to our house it's
understood that we
we will share everything and you're not
expected to bring in
anything
but most most gatherings here it's
understood that you bring a plate or you
bring something to offer and everybody
shares which is a good thing as well
you know i'm not saying ours is better
than you know it's just a matter of
perspective because that's probably the
influence we got from being under the
spanish for 300 years when i first
realized what bring appointment
you'd be surprised in filipinos here
when they invite you to their party they
expect you to bring
containers but but that is to bring food
away